[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir des milliers
de maliens ont manifesté partout dans le
pays ce vendredi ils ont répondu à
l'appel de la junte contre les sanctions
ouest africaine qui frappe le pays nous
retrouverons notre correspondant serge
daniel dès le début de ce journal à
bamako
des manifestations aussi en tunisie
malgré les interdictions de manifester
et un important dispositif policier est
contre cette fois ci le président kaïs à
m à l'occasion du 11e anniversaire de la
chute de ben ali nous irons sur place
dans son journal
la coupe d'afrique des nations vu par
les supporters des équipes du sénégal et
de la guinée des rivaux sportifs qui se
sont neutralisés aujourd'hui en faisant
match nul mais vous verrez que les
supporters sont très mobilisés et
espèrent voir leur équipe remporter sept
reportages à suivre
ils étaient des milliers ce vendredi à
manifester partout au mali à l'appel de
la junte militaire mobiliser contre les
sanctions des certaines instances
internationales fermeture des frontières
de la cedeao embargo sur les échanges
commerciaux et sur les transactions
financières des sanctions qui menacent
l'économie d'un pays parmi les plus
pauvres au monde et déjà éprouvée par
les violences et la pandémie on écoute
les manifestants
nous sommes venus pour soutenir le pays
que tout le monde sorte que tous les
musulmans sortent pour soutenir le pays
comme le dit un proverbe malien quand le
tom thomson est à peine les fils du pays
on répond à l'appel voilà pourquoi je
suis là le mali a appelé tout le monde
aujourd'hui tous les enfants du mali
sont sortis en réponse aujourd'hui
s'il vous enferme dans une pièce et
qu'ils s'en vont avec la clé que
feriez-vous de l'intérieur pensez vous
pouvoir négocier vous essayez d'abord de
sortir par la porte ou de fenêtre pour
aller chercher du pain pour nourrir
votre famille et vos enfants
elle et pour aller plus loin on retrouve
serge daniel correspondant rfi france 24
serge avoir la mobilisation très forte
peut-on dire que l'agente a réussi son
pari
aouidat voulait palin le pari de la
mobilisation actuelle a été réussie est
réussie totalement réussi vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure celui que l'on
n'ait le temps vous avez interrogé aidez
nous sommes sortis pour défendre le pays
c'est au delà de la junte ceux qui sont
sortis les milliers de personnes qui
sont sorties ici à bamako à l'intérieur
en bouquetot à kayes à l'extrême ouest
ou encore ensuite du mali sont sortis
bout défendre le pays d'abord le pays
c'est quelque chose de très important
alors ils ont défendu le pays à
contrôler la les sanctions de la cedeao
de l'union économique et monétaire de
l'afrique de l'ouest est pour dire aussi
nous sommes balliet nous voulons l'unité
de notre pays il y avait sept deux
symboles au cours de ces différentes
manifestations
et alors dans les pancartes on a pu lire
certains messages des messages anti
français de certains manifestants
accusant le pays de tirer les ficelles
de ces sanctions ou d'abandonner tout
simplement le pays serge vous propose
qu'on écoute d'abord le ministre
français des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian et on en parle juste après
nous sommes et nous voulons rester au
mali mais pas à n'importe quel prix et
nous sommes somalie pour combattre le
terrorisme et pas pour autre chose nous
allons réunir la coalition
la coalition internationale pour le
sahel pour faire le point de la
situation après les décisions prises par
la cedeao à la suite de la volonté de la
junte de ne pas mener la transition dans
les délais qu'elle avait initialement
prévu
certes daniel comment est-ce que vous
analysez justement ces messages anti
français qui ont pu être émis lors de la
manifestation
en réalité la france et le mali
ressemble à un vieux couple qui a des
problèmes et qui ne veut pas divorcer
voilà pour les maliens et c'est valable
également pour les français vous savez
aujourd'hui une crise diplomatique et
politique cela par billet à mâcon c'est
évident il tension mais au même moment
il faut savoir que sur le territoire
national au nord l'armée malienne et
l'armée française mais dans la mer sont
en train de lutter contre le terrorisme
sont en train de traquer les terroristes
sur le terrain j'ai lu encore tout à
l'heure un communiqué de markale qui
disait que avec l'armée malienne et
s'était confirmée par les fonds sableux
malienne il y à du résultat sur le
terrain d'autres en fait ça ressemble à
un vieux couple qui a des problèmes mais
qui ne veut pas divorcer et on se
demande justement qu'elles sont plus
largement les sorties de crise possible
à ce stade car malgré les sanctions la
junte dip ou poursuivre des discussions
avec la cédéao par exemple
ça c'est très important le ministre le
porte-parole de but du gouvernement le
colonel maïga a été très clair aux
ministres aux lors du meeting il a dit
nous voulons négocier avec la cedeao les
portes du dialogue ne sont pas fermés la
semaine prochaine d'après nos
informations un une deux délégation
malienne se rendront au néo en
mauritanie en algérie deux pays voisin
du mali qui ne sont pas de la cedeao qui
n'ont pas formé des frontières question
de pouvoir contourner l'embargo
mais pas pour longtemps parce qu'il va
falloir retourner à la case elle
négociations entre et ce qui se dit ici
d'ailleurs c'est que le fut le téléphone
la fonction toujours entre les
responsables fédéraux et le mali l'idée
c'est de trouver une durée de transition
restaurer responsable raisonnable on
parle d'un an euros maximum d'après ce
que nous avons a entendu dans des
chancelleries attendait dans les
chancelleries merci beaucoup serge
daniel pour toutes ces explications en
direct de bamako
en tunisie aussi plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont manifesté pour marquer
leur opposition au président kaïs aed à
l'occasion du 11e anniversaire de la
chute du dictateur ben ali et ceci
malgré un important dispositif
policier et l'interdiction de manifester
le point avec notre correspondante l'ia
blaise c'est un anniversaire qui laisse
un goût amer pour les manifestants qui
étaient venus commémorer aujourd'hui la
date du 14 janvier 2011 cette date qui
marque la chute de l'ex-dictateur zine
el abidine ben ali et qui pendant dix
ans a été la date anniversaire de la
révolution elle a été changée l'année
dernière par le président république
cassayet qui a décidé que la célébration
d'anniversaire de la révolution devait
commencer au 17 décembre la date de
l'immolation du vendeur ambulant mohamed
bouazizi
alors pour les manifestants qui étaient
venus ce vendredi et qui avaient répondu
à l'appel de partis politiques tels que
le parti islamiste ennahda des partis de
gauche mais aussi un collectif le
collectif citoyen contre le coup d'état
pour ces manifestants il fallait bravé
l'interdiction de tout rassemblement
public en raison des restes l'inter mais
aussi marqué à la fois cet anniversaire
et leur opposition au présent qui
assaillent aide lorsqu'ils ont tenté de
briser les cordons de sécurité qui
étaient répartis tout au long de
l'avenue habib bourguiba
il ya eu des tensions des tensions entre
les manifestants et la police qui se
sont soldées par des échauffourées des
bousculades des agressions parfois même
de journaliste et puis aussi un des jets
d'eau qui ont été lancées par les
camions de police pour disperser les
foules alors aujourd'hui pour la plupart
des opposants à cassayet d' ce
resserrement sécuritaire symbolise selon
leurs mots la dérive autoritaire que
peut prendre le régime de qaïs et laith
qui s'est octroyé tous les pouvoirs
depuis le 25 juillet d'autres réclament
la mise en place urgente d'un dialogue
entre kaïs ayed et les partis politiques
même les partis d'opposition mais aussi
un la société civile et puis bien sûr
les forces syndicales les forces
syndicales qui critiquent aujourd'hui
beaucoup l'action du gouvernement
désigné par cas et cède notamment sur le
plan des réformes économiques
chez les voisins algériens c'est
l'épidémie de coville qui inquiète les
malades hospitalisés liêu couronne à
virus serait six fois plus important en
un mois avec à peine 30% de vacciner le
pays tente de résister à une quatrième
vague forte duo variant au micron fin
décembre le gouvernement a annoncé
l'instauration prochaine d'un pass
vaccinale pour tous les plus de 18 ans
on passe à la coupe d'afrique des
nations qui termine sa première semaine
ce dimanche et c'était le duel très
attendu du groupe b entre les lions de
la teranga et le syli national il s'est
finalement soldée par un match nul et
vierge le sénégal et la guinée sont des
rivaux des vieux rivaux sur le plan
sportif et les supporters s'étaient
fortement mobilisés reportage de nos
correspondants à dakar et à conakry saha
sakho elimane dao est mal et diakité
au pied du monument de la renaissance de
dakar des supporteurs en transe pour
soutenir leur équipe l'enjeu est de
taille la guinée est un pays frère avec
lequel le sénégal entretient une
rivalité sportive depuis toujours pas
question pour pape de perdre ce match
c'est la gare le bonheur comme ras
lanouf ville à l'honneur il ya les
délais ou nos aînés
[Musique]
après une première mi-temps plutôt terne
les lions passe enfin à l'offensive les
supporteurs rongent leur frein la
tension est palpable le but tant attendu
ne viendra pas
en guinée aussi on s'est fortement
mobilisée cela fait 22 ans que le syli
national n'a pas battu les lions
sénégalais alors quand le match se
termine finalement par un nul les
guinéens eux applaudissent
nous pensons que nous méritions avoir au
moins en moins devenus des cas c'est un
match nul avec le sénégal qui est la
bête noire depuis toujours et ça c'est
une joie que je ne saurais vous
expliquer franchement je suis très
content c'est un match nul mais pour moi
c'est une victoire
au sénégal c'est la déception les
supporteurs garde toutefois espoir pour
la suite de la compétition
il faut passer par des difficultés aux
abords d'une bonne chose c'est ça la vie
cette année c'est la bonne pour vous
je vous rends
[Musique]
la guinée et le sénégal occupe pour
l'heure la première place ex-aequo de
leur groupe
ce mois de janvier on célèbre la
naissance de jean baptiste poquelin dit
molière 400 ans que ces pièces traverse
les époques et le monde l'occasion
d'aller au sénégal tient où il fait
partie des auteurs français les plus
connus et appréciés
reportage auprès d'une troupe qui joue
le médecin malgré lui en wolof et pour
ceux qui sont pas bilingues ou vos amis
le texte original en français sarah sa
cour
c'est en wolof que sganarelle et martin
se dispute dans cette scène bien connu
du médecin malgré lui et dans cette
langue très parlée au sénégal
la comédie de molière n'a rien perdu de
son mordant
et la troupe cas douillard arts
travaille d'arrache-pied sur cette pièce
qu'elle présentera au public dans les
prochains mois une expérience unique
mais exigeante pour ces comédiens
qui
s'est passé face et
c'est par amour pour sa langue
maternelle et pour molière que mamadou
diom a traduit fidèlement ce texte en
wolof selon lui le dramaturge français
dcri à la perfection la société
sénégalaise d'aujourd'hui comme celle
vue elle a tellement les thématiques qui
la
décrit nous sont familières les
violences conjugales
la médecine
pendant
au sénégal molière est également présent
dans les lycées où il figure au
programme notamment en classe de seconde
la vie et l'oeuvre de l'auteur sont
enseignés avec passion par ce professeur
la quatrième représentation
imaginaire les intéresse parce que les
strates et captivante ensuite molière
est un auteur qui écrit très bien il est
un classique
tous ces réseaux là et pour l'enfiler
c'est un coût qui est très intéressant
pour les élèves qui attire l'attention
ou encore racines font partie des
auteurs également enseigné au sénégal
c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal de l'afrique merci à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivis de bamakois yaoundé
en passant par tunis restez avec nous
car l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]